bonsoir françois poule et mathis merci
de répondre ce soir à nos questions en
direct sur arte france donc les
ambassadeurs des vingt-sept auprès de
l'union européenne ont donné leur aval à
une application provisoire à compter du
1er janvier de l'accord commercial
trouvé la semaine dernière avec le
royaume uni est ce que c'est bon signe
en vue d'une approbation finale des
eurodéputés le mois prochain alors de
toute façon demain on peut s'attendre à
une adoption formelle de cet accord par
les 27 chefs d'états membres de l'union
européenne
donc cela sera fait par les chefs
d'états membres et ça c'est très
important politiquement
et puis après il y aura deux approbation
qui sont absolument indispensables à
obtenir d'une part l'approbation du
parlement britannique
cela ne devrait pas poser de problème
sera aura lieu probablement mercredi à
la chambre des communes il n'y a pas de
problème puisque finalement brayonne
sommes dispose d'une majorité
confortable et en plus le parti
travailliste a dit aussi qu'il
approuvait cet accord il faudra ensuite
le parlement européen on vient de le
voir
le parlement européen a estimé que 1200
pages d'un accord aussi complexe ne
peuvent pas être contrôlés en si peu de
temps et donc de nom d'un délai serré
occasion pour laquelle la parution au
journal officiel de l'accord qui
interviendra probablement jeudi sera
validera cet accord à partir du 1er
janvier
mais cet accord sera transitoire et
laissera parlement européen d'ici le 28
février prochain
la marge de temps qui lui permettra de
d'évaluer la portée de cet accord est de
juger cet accord en connaissance de
cause
voilà à peu près vous redonnez mais
globalement on peut dire aujourd'hui que
cet accord est quasiment acquis alors
justement cette marge de manoeuvre un
saut délai durant lequel l'accord
l'application de l'accord sera
provisoire il ya quand même ça laisse
quand même une place peut-être pour un
couac en tout cas la france affirme
qu'elle sera dès le premier jour de
cette application provisoire vigilante à
la bonne mise en oeuvre de l'accord est
ce qu'un faux pas est possible tout le
monde durant ce délai
non je ne crois pas qu'elle ne faut pas
soit possible d'une part parce que
l'accord sera formellement adopté par
voie du jeu
l'officiel de l'union européenne et par
voie de la loi britannique
donc il sera officiel dans les faits ce
qui est possible c'est qu'effectivement
il y ait des phases d'adaptation avec
certains couacs mais pas du tout en
rapport avec ce qu'aurait coûtés anodine
c'est à dire l'absence d'accord qui
aurait créé une véritable situation de
chaos frontières imaginez une absence
d'accord c'était une situation dans
laquelle l'union européenne et la grande
bretagne étaient finalement dans
situation de pays totalement étranger
qui aurait eu à un vent à réinventer
complètement leur relation or ces
relations par cet accord sont
parfaitement codé et donc elle devrait
permettre effectivement d'avoir une plus
grande fluidité
cela dit il ne faut pas considérer que
le fait que cet accord eut lieu supprime
tous les obstacles aux frontières et
pourra faire en sorte que finalement il
n'y ait plus de files d'attentes aux
frontières et c'est parce que certes
s'il n'y a plus de quotas s'il n'y a
plus de tarifs douaniers comme cela est
indiqué de manière très précise dans
l'accord par contre il y aura des
contrôles
il y aura des loisne il y aura des
contrôles sur la normalité des produits
sur la respectabilité ses produits par
rapport aux normes zorro
environnementale par rapport aux normes
sociales bref une véritable frontière se
rétablit et ça c'est un phenom un
phénomène nouveau qui pour l'instant n'a
pas été encore véritablement perçu
raison pour laquelle par exemple le
ministre mais michael gove en grande
bretagne a mis en garde ses propres
concitoyens surtout ces entreprises en
disant attention il faut que vous soyez
prêt et il y aura des formalités
on estime par exemple il faudra cinq
fois plus de papier à remplir à la
frontière entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne pour pouvoir
continuer les échanges dans des
conditions à peu près acceptable
donc il ya véritablement un frein et de
toute façon ce 1er janvier va constituer
une date forcément importante qui sera
une véritable rupture dans les relations
entre l'union européenne et la grande
bretagne alors sur la question de la
pêche 1 qui a causé pas mal de
souci pour justement parvenir à faire
aboutir ces négociations entre les deux
parties pourquoi dit-on finalement que
les pêcheurs français sont les grands
vainqueurs et que les pêcheurs
britannique
les perdants imaginez que bon il johnson
avait promis dans un premier temps
d'ailleurs de récupérer la totalité des
poissons dans ses eaux territoriales et
finalement dans le premier rapport les
premières négociations
on parlait de 60% de récupération du
poisson dans les eaux britanniques et
l'accord final finalement ne parle que
de 25% de restitution des quotas de
poisson aux britanniques par les
européens sur une période est allé là
cinq ans et demi et donc pour les
pêcheurs on peut comprendre pour les
pêcheurs britannique on peut comprendre
que c'est une est une forme de trahison
par rapport aux promesses qui avaient
été faites par ben johnson
disons les choses clairement cet accord
a été obtenu par ce que boris johnson a
fait une concession énorme ou
concessions très importante sur un des
trois dossiers qui était vraiment
indispensable à l'obtention d'un accord
celui de la pêche
il a fait cette concession aux européens
moyennant quoi les européens ont fait
d'autres concessions ils ont fait par
exemple la concession d'admettre que la
cour de justice de luxembourg n'était
pas forcément compétente pour juger des
différents ils ont fait aussi d'autres
concessions en admettant l'idée que la
grande-bretagne récupérer le contrôle de
sa politique commerciale avec toutefois
des bémols puisque finalement cette
récupération de politique commerciale se
fait sous l'oeil avisé de l'union
européenne qui sera vigilant à faire
attention à ce que la grande-bretagne ne
s'éloigne pas trop des normes
européennes normes environnementales les
normes sociales
faute de quoi il y aurait alors lac des
sanctions et des manoeuvres qui vise à
compenser probablement par des taxes cet
écart que la grande-bretagne
effectuerait par rapport à l'union
européenne et rapidement françois baudet
mathis est ce que dans plusieurs années
un moyen
et long terme boris johnson il risque de
payer justement cette lourde concessions
faites dans le secteur de la pêche
il le paiera pas au niveau de la pêche
qui représente quand même une marge dans
le produit intérieur brut britannique et
donc je pense qu'il peut le payer si
véritablement le break site
ça on le verra pas tout de suite on le
verra dans les deux ou trois années qui
viennent est un échec si le break site
se traduit par un affaiblissement de
l'économie britannique par rapport à
l'économie européenne
là il sera en échec mais dans cette
affaire tout le monde sait que le break
site de toute façon est une aventure
perdant perdant perdant pour les
britanniques perdante pour l'union
européenne l'accord qui a été conclu ne
permet qu'une seule chose c'est de
limiter les dégâts et c'est bien de cela
dont il s'agit
boris johnson quelque part a sauvé sa
situation pour les mois qui viennent
probablement mais il n'a pas sauvé la
situation pour savoir comment lui est
capable avec sa majorité de gérer une
situation dans laquelle la
grande-bretagne pourrait se trouver de
plus en plus acculé il ya eu aussi un
autre phénomène c'est que les états unis
avec un nouveau président joe biden qui
est ascendance irlandaise qui n'était
pas du tout favorable breakes site ne
sera peut-être pas très ardent à jouer
dans le sens d'accords commerciaux très
avantageux avec la grande bretagne
ça risque de se compliquer à suivre donc
merci beaucoup françois pour les métis
je rappelle que vous êtes journalistes
spécialistes europe 1